what's the latest tattoo you have I
actually got um my wife's portrait on my
arm oh
that is beautiful roughly a year after
tying the knot with Nicola Peltz
Brooklyn Beckham pays tribute with some
new ink I don't have the words who's
also left speechless Jennifer Hudson
when the social media Chef stops by her
talk show now I hear you have like a lot
of tattoos how many do you have
um in between like 80 to 100 I'm not
really sure really quite a few yeah he's
got plenty to show off but the new
additions could be the most meaningful
ones yet oh my God what's the latest
tattoo you have I actually got um my
wife's portrait on my arm that was my
last one I got that is so sweet can you
show us of course we want to see don't
we
all right he's gonna show us
Shake It Off oh my God that is beautiful
the first camera I bought myself and
then a compass is something that you
kind of have to really take your time
with and if you really if something
really means something to you you should
get it and that's your latest one that's
my latest one and I actually got on the
same day
um some of the lyrics of the song that
we walked down that she walked down the
aisle to that track
Songbird it's a Fleetwood Mac gem
because I feel that when I'm with you
it's all right he's so sentimental of
course Jen also has to ask about the
couple's A-list pal Selena Gomez is like
a good friend yeah so she says we're
throttle yep cell made it official on
New Year's Eve riding on the gram fine
call us a throuple hashtag forever plus
one
she's such a she's such a sweet girl
um
she's a very very sweet girl obviously
very talented and you know I I love when
my wife makes new friends especially
like really great friends and you know
we all get along so um yeah
oh they look gorgeous nice
that's a good old friend to have huh
y'all speaking of friends there were
plenty at Brooklyn and Nicholas big date
last year where 600 guests stepped out
for their ideas one of the pop culture
moments of 2022 was your unbelievable
wedding I think like you know I married
my best mate and while the wedding came
with a three million dollar price tag
Brooklyn's one year anniversary gift is
priceless
that is beautiful Brooklyn's truly like
my best friend and I feel like I'm
living with my best friend and also like
the love of my life so it's been nice we
love each other's company he's so
sensible pencils
[Music]